there's tonight's starting pitcher eli
morgan for the tribe will be throwing to
ryan lavarnway eli will see if he can
continue his development here against
the top team in the national league
central the milwaukee brewer colt wong
digs in
and that hit him so morgan hits wong who
gets hit quite often he stands right on
top of the plate here's eduardo escobar
swung on socked high in the air to deep
right center field reyes is back onto
the track makes the catch tagging going
the second is long and the throw is off
the mark wong advancing to second moving
to third is colton wong with two outs
and he stands there for avi garcia down
low and knocked down by levarnway
brock they're going to score the run
here i think ryan lavarnway went down
and
touched the ball with his mask
can't do that and wong is going to score
the run
lavanway has no idea what he did
home plate umpire john bacon was right
on it check this out yeah good call i
mean any part of your equipment that you
touch a live ball with is an extra base
yeah he stops it with his mask right
there that's uh
interference iran's going to score
that's going to be an e2 on la barnway
just barely touches the baseball with
his mask now adrian hauser pitches with
a lead era is a 2-6-0
since the all-star break he has been
terrific yeah four of his last five
starts have been really good
chopped up the middle marias cuts it off
low throw and it's wide of the mark and
miles straw is aboard to start the game
see how it's officially ruled well i'll
tell you what it looks like he's got
pretty good movement but he just tops
this ball
and uranus has to get rid of it quickly
he knew that with straw going down the
line there goes the runner and running
that's a good throw
the call is safe mile straw with stolen
base number 25
and the straight continues tell you what
that was a really good quick release by
narvaez gave him a chance watch the hand
get in there and that was really close
it was close so now that's 30
consecutive steals for the indians an
error and a walk and the indians have
two on with one out and now the indians
hottest hitter fan mail reyes to the
plate there goes mile straw vermeer is
running as well it's a double steal
standing narvaez never even got out of
his crouch
three and two now here he comes
and he got him big curveball and reyes
strikes out for the second out of the
inning that is a yellow hammer tonight
bobby bradley hitting 217 with a dozen
homers
and another base hit delivers two
bradley puts the indians on top
hitting in the clutch seems to be his
thing
yeah they come right back and uh he
doesn't waste any time jumping on the
first pitch
batting a cool 400 over his last 10
games
big bouncer it goes by uris and bradley
will go to third and chang
into second standing i'll tell you what
the brewers they caught him flat-footed
right there aureus has made two blunders
in the first and it's been costly thus
far boy i'll say base is loaded two down
two to one cleveland first inning ryan
levarnway the batter veteran catcher
ground ball to third escobar has that
and throws to colton long they get the
force out on zimmer and the inning
finally comes to the close the off walks
second time ramirez is walked front bill
reyes coming up struck out his first
time
runner goes swinging a miss
struck him out and jose ramirez has his
second stolen base of the night number
23 on the year the indians have quite
four bags already saw two down now and a
runner 90 feet away for you chang
high fly ball into center field lorenzo
kane moving over into right center
calling off avi garcia making the catch
eli morgan will go back to work facing
omar narvaez
norvya's on the first pitch down the
line that one hops the fence narvaez
trucking his way to second
and he is in there with a double omar
narvaez with a lead off double here in
the fourth inning so one down and that
will bring up luis urias here's a 2-2
and urea sends one high and deep that is
way back and gone
luis suryas with a two run homer
and he gives the brewers the lead
number 20 for ureas it's 3-2 milwaukee
so luis urreas goes deep to left here in
cleveland and now the indians have that
tying run in scoring position andres
jimenez will step to the plate
swinging a miss jimenez strikes out so
two down now and here's miles straw
there goes zimmer for third narvaez
can't get the ball out of his glove so
that'll be the indians fifth stolen base
of the night number 13 for
zimmer straw draws the walk and that'll
put runners on the corners or ahmed
rosario
uncontested stolen base once again they
had a double steel standing up earlier
council is going crazy darf i said what
do you want me to do what do you want me
to do yeah 2-1 pitch bouncer back up the
middle gloved on a short hop by rheous
in the throat of first is in time
luis urias with one of the more
challenging plays that he's had all
evening long made it look routine
pitch to escobar swinging a high fly
deep into right field if it's fair it's
gone it is way fair and way gone
eduardo escobar on the first pitch of
the fifth inning makes it a 4-2 brewers
lead
he homered in the last game that the
brewers played this time he goes exit
stage right bases are loaded now brewers
have this young pitcher on the ropes
luis urias is going to bat now with the
bases full
and they yep hit it hit the glove that's
gonna be a catcher's interference
wow
another error
on the barn way
another run in gonna be five to two a
late swing and a fast ball and
we got the thumb of the glove you don't
see that very often normally the fingers
of the glove and it's gonna be the end
of the line for eli morgan so a lefty
coming in to face teles brewers have two
runs in here in the fifth hinches is on
his way
and rowdy teles pops the first pitch up
right out in front of home plate lavon
way
snares it for out number two as the
bases are still loaded for the number
nine hitter lorenzo kane oh lorenzo kane
back legs one deep to left there she
goes
a grand slam from lorenzo kane the
brewers busted wide open kane with his
eighth home run of the year
9-2
milwaukee
back to the top of the lineup swung on
line drive caught by the second baseman
ximena is a tumbling grab for the fourth
time this year escobar has gone deep in
back-to-back games turns around hits
right-handed now the switch hitter
and he sends one deep that's gonna go
escobar another home run
look out he's getting hot incoming
bunches for these guys one lefty one
righty and escobar makes it 10 to two
brewers number 27 on the year for
escobar his fifth as a brewer to the
sixth inning and adrian hauser is still
out there he's only given up one hit
one-two pitch to lavarnway
struck him out looking sinker on the
outside corner inning over five
strikeouts for adrian howser in six
really impressive innings runners around
the corners now for you chang
slow chopper let's get it out
and then a nice play by escobar
indians get a run it's now 10-3 and
hunter strickland on the mound to try to
finish this one off tonight in the night
in the air they should do it foul
territory escobar is under it
and the brewers put win number 87 in the
books
magic number down to nine a division
title is right in front of him